vor 72 stunden kam die diagnose das hat
vor allem viele fragen deswegen
aufgebracht weil das eigentlich auch
bedeuten würde
früher als wir alle erfahren haben
musste donald trump bereits dass er
erkrankt ist und die große frage ist er
weiter gereist obwohl er schon symptom
hat oder vielleicht sogar ein positives
testergebnis das wäre ein skandal muss
man ja wirklich so sagen ja das ist das
was sich jetzt glaube ich alle darf
dieser pressekonferenz fragen also diese
pressekonferenz wäre eigentlich fast ein
anlass für eine zweite pressekonferenz
um diese pressekonferenz zu erklären
denn das was natürlich alle kollegen
dort sind washington unser kollege
herbert bauernebel das auch vor ort
wissen wollten wir seit wann weiß denn
der präsident dass er krank ist nicht
selber an fühlt er sich krank sondern
sein wann weiß er denn dass er krank ist
da hatte man das gefühl dass es so
ungefähr 35 stunden her es jetzt kam die
antwort seines leibarztes das ist schon
deutlich länger her so das ist
hochinteressant denn präsident donald
trump ist in den letzten tagen gereist
er hat an veranstaltungen so genannten
fundraiser wo es darum geht geld für die
publica partei für seinen wahlkampf ein
zusammen teilgenommen
und wenn er da schon gewusst haben
sollte dass er eigentlich gronau positiv
ist dann wäre das natürlich ein skandal
was man jetzt schon sagen kann ist er
hat auf jeden fall gewusst dass menschen
mit denen er ganz viel zeit verbracht
hat in den tagen vorher corona positiv
getestet worden sind er musste also
davon ausgehen als er gereist ist das
eine gefahr für andere menschen
darstellt und das ist natürlich etwas
was auch politisch enorme implikationen
in den nächsten tagen haben wird dass
der us-präsident sich in die
gesellschaft in die gegenwart anderer
menschen begibt obwohl er weiß seine
engste beraterin im weißen haus hobbys
hat sich mit schweren symptomen
abgemeldet ist positiv auf gerona
getestet ihm ging es anscheinend auch
nicht so gut und dann trotzdem noch
weiter zu reisen
ironischerweise in eine veranstaltung in
seinem eigenen golf club im bundesstaat
new jersey das wäre nicht nur eine
gesundheitliche welt news sondern das
wäre auch ein politischer skandal der
vermutlich enorme enorme auswirkungen
auf die bevorstehenden wahlen in 32
tagen haben wird mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren